tu es pour en parler nous sommes avec
didier maïsto président de sud radio
bonsoir didier maïsto le gouvernement
qui finalement reculé retire cette page
de son site une bonne nouvelle que
qu'est ce que vous y voyez comme finir
bonsoir oui c'est une bonne nouvelle en
tout cas c'est une vraie nouvelle ce
n'est pas une fête newscom moment comme
on dit et en fait ce gouvernement mais
c'est pas nouveau a semble t'il un
problème avec les médias avec
l'indépendance des médias il n'a que ces
mots à la bouche indépendance des médias
garant de l'indépendance des médias
mais je crois que le les médias n'ont
pas besoin du gouvernement pour être
indépendant et n'ont pas besoin d'être
garanti mais cette histoire n'est pas
n'est pas nouvelle nous l'avons vu à
l'occasion des mouvements sociaux à
l'occasion des gilet jaune est dans la
tête d'emmanuel macombe a refleuri une
vieille idée une vieille lune qui a été
pour partie défendu par par la classe
politique sur la création vous en
souvenez j'étais venu sur votre antenne
pour dire c'était une très mauvaise idée
de ce fameux conseil de déontologie
journalistique et de médiation il s'agit
de labelliser finalement les médias qui
des endroits l'imprimatur de l'exécutif
et les médias qui sont censés aux pages
et des faut se lever
alors effectivement au dîner mais cette
nouvelle section a présenté en ce
qu'elle a été retirée des liens vers des
articles de médias ces médias donc et
alors il ya ceux effectivement qui
luttent dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire france info libération 20
minutes
il ya donc selon le gouvernement les
bons et les mauvais élèves
j'avoue c'est pas que je vais la prendre
à alerter france vous avez été souvent
accusés d'être des propagateurs de
fausses nouvelles
à la solde du gouvernement russe
alors que beaucoup de chaînes sont
financés à la fois par les jeux pensés
ou par d'autres états souverains
ça n'a jamais posé le moindre problème
on voit bien plat qu'on est tout à fait
dans la politique politicienne
cette liberté des français des citoyens
elle s'est exprimée très fortement via
les réseaux sociaux
et puis il ya un certain nombre de
chaînes de stations de radio des
journalistes indépendants de gens qui
sont allés filmer les événements dans la
rue qui ont montré une différente de
différentes choses de l'intérieur
et malheureusement il semblerait que cet
exécutif en beaucoup les médias qui vont
dans son sens et n'aime pas beaucoup
l'esprit critique donc c'est très bien
que ce cette page a été retirée
d'ailleurs je l'avais dit à cette
hauteur général du r cela dira agents du
conseil de déontologie puisque je les
croise et juste avant le confinement à
côté de la radio et elle m'avait proposé
de faire partie de discuter pour
intégrer ce conseil dans les pas
question parce que vous rendez pas qu en
réalité que vous êtes sous la coupe de
deux de l'exécutif et les médias ne
peuvent pas obéir
quel que soit le gouvernement dans un
régime démocratique
dans un régime républicain aux
injonctions des uns et des autres et
sais pas je regrette à des
fonctionnaires du service d'information
du premier ministre de décider s'ils
doivent labellisé une fine pas pour cela
nous avons des du public
nous prenons nos risques nous vérifions
nos informations et nous vous en oeuvre
de pluralisme de donner la parole à tout
le monde nous en est un exemple
et je pense que sud radio aussi donc
nous n'avons pas besoin de savoir le
doigt sur la couture du pantalon si ce
que nous faisons doit voir l'imprimatur
du gouvernement
les sept bénéfice du doute quand même il
s'agissait d'une crise il s'agit d'une
crise sanitaire grave
n'est-il pas important effectivement de
deux livré dans ce domaine précisément
des informations fiables et justes et et
vous le pensez peut-être un peuple
le but du gouvernement quand même
l'objectif premier
j'y crois pas du tout pour être honnête
imaginez je je je je vous renvoie des
questions si un l'occasion de toutes les
faits qui news propagée par l'exécutif
je vous rappel d'histoire des masques et
libération alors que nous vous l'avions
fait dès le début libération en fait une
enquête la semaine dernière et a crié au
mensonge d'état puisque le directeur
général de la santé jérôme salomon avait
dit que la stratégie de l'état avait
évolué et changé et c'est pas du tout du
tout la stratégie n'a pas changé songez
que de 2012 a aujourd'hui on devait
comme commander 100 millions de masques
par an une seule commande a été honoré
il en est de même pour les tests il en
est de même pour tous les débats autour
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine et imaginez
si les médias s'étaient tues et avait
laissé comme ça
la propagande de l'exécutif se dérouler
on serait déjà un peu dans une forme de
régime autocratique ou dictatorial il
est heureux que les médias puissent
critiquer en toute indépendance et
l'attitude que doit être aussi positive
mais que les débats s'organisent dans
une démocratie c'est comme ça que cela
fonctionne et rappelez-vous aussi de 2 6
bat aniane porte parole du gouvernement
qui nous expliquait que les masques ne
servait à rien aujourd'hui l'om s et
l'académie de médecine et tous les gens
un petit peu sérieux dans la mesure où
le corona virus se propage par les
postillons comprend et suggère et
conseille fortement et norman
obligatoire le port de masque en réalité
tout ça et vous avez expliqué aussi que
nous étions tout à fait un cap
de mettre correctement un masque alors
que cet après midi même
en fin de matinée le président la
république s'est rendu dans une école à
enlever son masque il a touché la
réajuster un certain nombre de fois
alors qu'on ne doit évidemment pas
touché son masque à lens il s'agit
d'avoir des béni-oui-oui et des médias à
la vôtre ce sera sans sud radio et il
est heureux seuls les idiots ne changent
pas d'avis que ça te page internet
délétère était retirée merci beaucoup
didier maille tort d'avoir été en direct